WHATREONOCLONAL ANTODIES.
ASK YOU DOCTOR.
PE, THANK YOU KEN
CONGRESSN, THANK YOU.
SETOR ELIZABETH RREN LASHING
OUT AT THE WLD'SICHESTAN.
LOTMART THAN HER,
EL MUS AFTER HE CALL HER,
ENAT KAREN" OVER TWIER
RIFT OVER TAX POLIC
IT START AFT MUSK WAS NAME
"TE" MAGAZIN TOERSON OF THE
YE.
H FAR LEF SENATOR WARRETWEETED N
TAX CODE STHE PSON OF THE
YEAR WILLCTUAY PAY TAXES ANDSTON
LES TO WHICHKESPOED
U REMIND MEF WHEN I WAS A
KID AND MY FRIENDS ANGRY MOMWOUT
EVERYONE FOR N REASON.
PLEASE DON'T CL THE MANAGER ON
ME SENATOR KAR.
D ADDING IFOUPEN YOUR EYES
FOR O SECONDS HEOULDEALIZE
THAT IILL PAY MOR TAXES TN
ANY ERICAN HISTORYHIS YEARCHKMA.
AFR TTESPONSE, WREN
COUL'T LET IT GO.
A BEARING ON MSN --
JOY REID SWED TO LAS OUT EVENMO.
TA A LOOK.
>> THE WOR'S RICHEST
FRLOADERVIDELY HAS SOME
VERY TN SKIN.
THEY HAD TOUTER SPACEND
ACQUIRE HOTHEYID THIS ALL ON
THEI OWN
WHENHEY WERE SUBDIZED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVEMENTND
SUBSIDIZED BY EVERY WAITRES ANDR
WHPAIDHEIR TAXES.
THIS IS WROAN ELON MUSK
NEEDSO EAT AIG DISH OF THA
>> Sean: HE OTE LACK OF
RE WITH A REAIONUTHOR OF
NOW A "NEW YORK TES"
BEST SLER,FOR SUCH A TIMASTHIS,G
WITHLAY.
I FIND THIS INTERESTING.
IATCH THE SERIESHE M THATBUILT .
THE FORWARDS, THEOCKEFELLERS,
THE CARGIE'S.
ALL OF THEM RY INTERESTING ANDI,
KAYLEE, AS A MODN-DAVERSION
OF THAT.
AND WOULD THINK THAT SOMEONE
LIKE ELIBETH WARREN, NEW
GRN DEA CULTISTOU LIKE
THE FACT THAT HE IS THIING
BO GETTING NEW TECHNOLOG I
FASCINATED  WHAT HE DS
DANT TO S HIM BE
SUESSFUL.
>> WOULD N DOUBT.
ELONUSK IS AN AMERIN SUCCESSSTY.
CA TO THIS COUNTRY,ENT TO
COLLEGE, TOOK A $100,000 SDENT
LO, WORKEDWO JOBS TO PAY
DOWN OFF, AND NOW IS A
LLIONAIRE PAYING MOR TAXES,
AS YOU NOT, THAN ANYONE IN
HISTORY AND THIS YE ALO HE
NOTED.
I THINK WH YOU LK AT WOKE IS
ON WHICH IS A VERY POWERL
UG, THIS IS AMANDA AM NOT
GOING TO BA BLIONRE
ELITES, NOT GNG T S WHAT IS
WOKE, SAY WOO IS LIBAL, SAY
WHATS EXPECTED OF ME.
I AM GOING TJUST BE ME ANDE
IS DOING TT'S, CTING THROUGH
THE NSE, HOLDING A POWERL
SENATO ACCOUNTLE.
HE HAS DONE THE SAME WITH
BERNIE SANRS.
I AM SO PRESD BY H.
YOU TAKE A LK AT THE MOST
TERESTING PEOP IN AMERICA
CO I COULDN'T AGR MORE.
DESERVES THATITLE AT THIS
POT.
>> Sea HE A FCINATING
GUY,LAY.
I WATCH WHAT HEOES.
I'M AMAZED BY IT.
RIT NOTHE LIFEBLOOD O THE
WORLSCONOMY IS OIL G, AND
AL
IF THE IS NAPER ANALOGY
THAT COMES ALONGNDE HELPS
VELO IT, ALL THE PER TO H
HIM.
HES ADVANCING THHUMAN
COITIO.
HE IS GONE FOR ALREADY.
VERYNTERESTED TOEEHATE
DOES NEXT.
LOOK, SEAN, IF US
FREELOADER, WE NEED A L MOR
FRIELY OWNERS.
RE'S WHAT HEOES.HE IMMIGRATEDROA
ASAYLEH SAID.
CAME TCHOOL HERE.MADE MONEY WIT.
AND THEN DIDED I THINK I CBUILD.
AND HE DID IT.
D THEN HE ALSO THOHT YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THIS COMBUSTION ANI INEROVERALLT
KE A L OF SENSE.
I ULD LIKE TO DEVELOP A NEW
CAR ANDOUNDED ON ELERICITY
TO HELPO CREE SOME ENERGY
INDEPEENCE, ANDE D THAT,
ANIN THE PROCESS,E HASBECOME THT
WOD.AND AS HE RIGHTFULLY TWE,S
ABOUT TOAY MOR TAXES THAN
ANYONE HASVER ID IN THE
HISTY OF THE OHMICUNITED STATESG
AT ARICA SHOULD B ABOUT.
HE I DAMIC, HE IS
SK-TING.
>> Sean: H IS NOT-
LOVE THE
I AM FASCINATED BY E GU
HE DN'T LIE ABOUT HIS
NATIONALS
CAER.
THAT A PLUS IN MYOOK.>> IZABETHY
IS JOY RD DEFENDED
ELABETH WARREN BSAYING THAT
ELONUSK WAS APPROPRTING.
DID YOU SEEHIS?
THE WORD TKAREN AND HIS INST
WITHENATOR KAREN.
AN SHE DID THATO DEFEND
ELIZABETH RRENHO LIED ABOUT
BEG A NATIVAMERICAN SO SHE
COULD GET AAWROFESSOR DROP
D THEN STOLE A RECIPE FROA
NATIVE AMERIN COOKBOOK CLEDPOWO.
>> Sean: KAYLEE, YOU GET THE
ST WORD.
AND CONGRULATIONS ON
"T NEW YORK TIME BEST
LLER.
>> THANK YOU
YOU WERE ITRUMENTAL IN AT.
IOULDAY THIS.
WE ND MOR NONPOLITICIAN IN
THEWAMP
I WAS IN THE SWA.
PPENO WORK FOR DONALD TRUMP,
E TE IS PREDENT OF OUR
TIME.WE NEED MOREEOPLE LIKE
EL MUSK GETTING  THE GAME
AND HE MIG BEOING THAT.
EETI ABOUT
BUILD BACK BTER.
HE IVERYOOD A BRANDING.
ELON MUSK MAY HAVA POLITICAL
FUTURE.
NEEMORE PEOPLEIKE HIM IN
THE SWAMP.
TAKES AOT OF COURAGEO GO
THE AND BAKITH WHAT IS
COORTABLE.
>> Sean: ION'T THINK
ELIZETH WARREN UNDERSTANDS
WHAA
BUNESS
THE'S A LOT OF RISKND A LOT
OF PEOPLE TH TRY, FAIL.
AND THOSE TT A SUCCESSFUL
ALSO B CELEBRAD.
AND GUESAT?
THATONEY IS NERS, AND THE
TAXE THAT HE IS PAYG IS
ENORMOUS.
AND